tesla yesterday ai day absolutely
nuts to watch this business continue to
execute during ai day artificial
intelligence day tesla continuously
updates the community on things that
they're doing around ai advancement the
ways that they're incorporating
artificial intelligence and they
announced two big things yesterday the
first the tesla bot which you can see
right here the tesla bot is a humanoid
it's literally a physical looking robot
that is supposed to do menial tasks it
according to elon musk is you know once
you have it do the menial task maybe you
can do other things too i mean maybe it
could be your buddy as well so when you
start to think about these tesla bots
the whole idea is that you can use
machine learning and artificial
intelligence and you can have them
eliminate dangerous repetitive boring
tasks the bot is five foot eight it has
a carrying capacity of 45 pounds it
weighs 125 pounds and it can dead lift
150 speed
just absolute speed demon at 5 miles an
hour and the arm extend lift is 10
pounds i think that we're watching the
very first
equivalent of the nfl combine for robots
right here
i want to see it compete in the combine
next up on the bench press is the tesla
bot
5 8 125 pounds with a deadlift of 150
pounds like it literally looks like
we're evaluating whether i want this one
or a different one i bet elon saw the
boston dynamics video of the robots like
jumping from block to block the other
day and was like yeah put dead lift on
the chart
we need to show them how much you can
deadlift theirs is sleeker looking too
than the boston dynamic i mean you think
it's cute does that oh god oh oh oh john
you think the robot is in the speaker
the ball got like wires coming out of
its shoulders this one's got like he's
like he's put a casing on it so people
can't see it you into the robot good job
we're not going down that narrative
down right away johnny robot all right
so tesla also not only did they announce
these tesla bots which actually look
pretty cool makes a ton of sense if
you're gonna remove all sorts of
dangerous repetitive boring tasks uh and
if you think of tesla being so heavily
automated in their factories it's kind
of a no-brainer that if you have the
technology chops and you've got the
manufacturing case
capability you can create these of
course you're gonna continue to automate
things this is part of the process of
automation it just happens to be that it
looks like a human
the other thing that they announced was
that they unveiled a new custom chip for
training artificial intelligence
networks in their data centers and so
the cnbc article basically outlaid three
key points the first is that tesla's
technology will be the fastest ai
training computer people like intel
nvidia graphcore among other companies
that make chips for these uh uh ai
training models but tesla will have the
fastest ai training chip on the market
the second is that the chips can help
train models for recognizing a variety
of different items from video feeds
collected by cameras inside of tesla
vehicles those training videos allow for
things like recognizing is that a person
crossing the street is that another car
is that an 18-wheeler is that a stop
sign what is that thing that just popped
into the road should i make a right or a
left am i allowed to make a right or a
left all kinds of different decisions
that you usually a human has to ingest
information synthesize it and then make
decisions tesla is building a way for
the full self-driving capability and in
order to be able to do that you have to
ingest the information through the
videos you have to be able to synthesize
it and you have to be able to act those
models that have the training capability
require extensive computing work the
computing work now with these ai chips
the last thing is that the work comes
two years after tesla began producing
vehicles containing custom-built ai
chips previously those chips help the
car's onboard software make decisions
very quickly in response to what's
happening on the road
this brings me to the most important
point about tesla people are finally
recognizing this is not a car company
this is a technology company this is an
artificial intelligence and machine
learning company and so my friend
andreas klinger had this great tweet
thread or two tweets first he said i
love how elon musk creates the mars
colony stack this is elon musk's master
plan first we have to be able to get to
mars so we're going to create rockets
that's spacex second once we get to mars
we are going to need to be able to get
around that's the vehicles and robots
with tesla third there are going to be
conditions that we need to actually be
able to go underground for shelter or
other purposes that's the boring company
while we're there we probably are going
to need food he has his brother kimball
musk working on urban farms on top of
that not only are we going to need to be
able to eat food but we are also going
to have to have power while on mars and
so that's solar city and tesla on top of
that it's probably going to be helpful
if all of a sudden there's all these
robots and
artificially intelligence driven
vehicles driving around that we have a
better way for humans and computers to
interface with each other and so that's
neuralink the ability for humans to get
super intelligence
and lastly if we're going to have all of
this computational power all this
artificial intelligence machine learning
etc on the mars colony we're going to
have to need a way to communicate have a
data connection that is the starlink
satellite work so when you look through
this mars colony stack the elon musk
master plan elon musk is building
various technologies that all are going
to come together a decade or two away
most likely and he's going to be able to
get us there now next once he continues
with the work that he's doing is we are
going to have more work that needs to be
done including things like 3d printed
medicine 3d printed furniture auto docks
space ports space factory shout out to
delia and varda and things like
autonomous resource drones so when we
start to look at what elon musk is doing
and what his master plan here is it is
fascinating to see a man who made 180
million dollars on by selling his last
business and he took it all and he put
it all in he pushed all the chips in
today he has rockets to get there he has
vehicles and robots to operate on the
surface of mars he's got underground
shelter with boring company underway
he's got things like food in the urban
farms with his brother he's got uh power
with solar city and tesla he's got the
human computer interface with neurolink
and then the data connection with
starlink elon musk right now is
undergoing the single most ambitious
plan on the entire
galaxy if he can get us from earth to
mars and he can create a true mars
colony it will probably be the single
greatest human feat in history in my
opinion we're talking about innovation
and technology elon's the definition of
it you see he's one of the greatest
innovators that we've seen um and i've
seen personally for sure but
yeah he he's gonna
he's doing everything i think he works
on so many different things it's it's
fascinating to see him
kind of go from project to project like
people didn't even know he was working
on these robots only people internally
knew that um it's it's fascinating he's
coming up with new ideas and new
technology every day are we worried
about the tesla bots is it weird that
there's a five foot eight 125 pounds
if he doesn't make him someone else is
going to true do we trust elon musk to
make the robots more than we trust
somebody else
i don't know i'm not messing with those
robots regardless of what happens you
you wouldn't mess wouldn't go on for
queen what do you mean get one oh to
clean my house no i don't even want in
my mind do all the boring dangerous
minute tackles i understand i understand
he may be filling up his tesla factory
with him i don't know right that's my
guess is that's what he's going to do is
he's going to basically look at within a
factory what are all of the things that
are the boring menial kind of dangerous
tasks and let's use these people to do
it remember it's all about root
memorization right when you're in a
factory this is my whole point about the
education system is uh and why i
invested in synthesis the entire
education system is built for a
industrial revolution time period where
people went and worked in factories what
do they say joe you're a 10 year old kid
sit down shut up don't move we're going
to tell you what to do we're going to
tell you exactly what to think and then
what you're going to do is we're going
to put you through the process of
education we're going to kick you out at
the end and then you're going to go get
a job in a factory and you're going to
do what you're told and if you're a good
boy and you work here for 40 years you
can work your way up off the factory
floor and eventually become management
that that was the system and all of a
sudden the system got
smashed when you added in
less and less people going into
factories less and less people going
into some sort of like root memorization
type job so if this whole kind of
intellectual or creative economy of the
digital world etc but two now is a lot
of the jobs around uh that rote
memorization or the factory workers or
uh long-haul drivers etc is going to be
replaced by computers
we were programming computers in the
education system you are a computer and
we simply said we're going to give you
all this information humans are actually
really stupid computers though imagine
if instead i could simply just upload
information into something that could
deadlift 150 pounds could pick up a box
weighing up to 10 pounds and i told it
all right here's what you're gonna do
today unload the truck
and the robot just did it and it did it
well didn't complain didn't ask for a
lunch break it didn't sit down and call
in sick like none of that [ __ ] just did
the job shut up and do what you're told
that's exactly what i was by the way
robot overlords i'm not i'm your friend
but i'm just saying like that is the
world that we're going to rather than
dealing with humans who have all these
complaints and unions and all this crazy
stuff can can you imagine the backlash
online when jeff bezos gets these and
and he everyone's they need a 15 hour
wait
they need a lunch break
bezos is like nah they're robots i
recharge 20 minutes yeah
i pay a one-time fee these things don't
get lunch they don't get water they
don't get anything they're working 24 7.
well you you do know that bill gates has
multiple times come out and said that he
believes that the robot should be taxed
i swear to god what
the pros and cons of taxing robotic
technology in the workplace and uh bill
gates has basically said uh where is it
he wants to tax robots but the eu is
saying no way
so uh
even the eu's like nah we're not doing
that he basically came out and uh he
said if a human worker does 50 000 of
work in a factory that income is taxed
if a robot comes in and does the same
thing you'd think we'd tax the robot at
a similar level
like
bill gates believes we should be taxing
robots elon musk is like i'm gonna build
robots it's gonna be amazing we're gonna
go to mars there's two different views
of the world here and so when you start
to think through uh the impact of this
one it's inevitable two humans are not
going to all of a sudden all be homeless
and unemployed right if you go back in
history it was like 90 plus percent of
humans were farmers
yeah that's what you did for a living
you were a farmer get out in the field
and get food
what did we do we use technology and
innovation to be able to get people from
being a farmer to go do other much more
productive things it's a positive in the
world that we did that imagine if every
single person today was still farming it
would be a waste of human potential so
all of a sudden we start to use the
robotics and what it's going to do is
it's going to get people out of
factories and get them out of driving
these long-haul drives etc yes there
will be pain in the short term for
people in those jobs but from an
overarching societal standpoint this
will drastically push us forward it will
open those people up to be able to do
much more productive things they have to
be retrained it is painful i understand
where people get the fear from we should
probably not tax the robots i don't
think that they're gonna fight back but
you never know they're gonna unionize
i mean is there gonna be a robot union i
don't know but like that makes no sense
right because if someone built uh the
assembly line right and and they went
out and said we're going to build a
better assembly line in-house and we're
going to you know make it ourselves
we're going to source all the materials
do all this stuff you would never tax
them right it's just a means of uh
increasing production and lowering costs
and all this stuff hey guys thanks so
much for watching that clip of the best
business show make sure you like and
subscribe to the channel turn on
notifications so you know when we go
live every weekday and then head to
sofi.com so that you can get an account
we can get after it